alright let's start with what kind of
compensation these CEOs receive how did
they get so typically at this stage in
you know when they're running these
companies they're getting paid in
options so they have an inherent value
when they're granted and now whenever
their stocks go up you know you see
these huge gains in the value of their
option packages packages we know how
much they actually get paid in cash
because a lot of these companies are
still profitless sure yeah it's a small
amount of I mean small it's it's
relatively small when you look at other
executives and their pay packages so it
is mostly equity which is why the value
of their pay is so high and why they're
on our Bloomberg pay index you know we
we value compensation as of a company's
fiscal year and so the games in these
biotech shares have really you know
added to the value of their pay so what
kind of companies are we talking about
and what do they do sure so we have a
couple of companies we have Juno and
kite they're both cancer therapy
developers and then we also have a
couple of other companies called radius
and anacor and they focus on rare
diseases what's interesting here is that
when I think biotech companies I think
about Biogen I think about Celgene
Gilead Sciences vertex names that we
hear so often are actively traded
they're not in this list right there
they're not and that's why this is so
surprising and really exciting for us
because we've we've crunched these
numbers and we've been able to add some
guys to these this highest paid
executives list that you wouldn't
necessarily see anywhere else so how do
they wind up cashing out so there's a
couple of ways I mean you know the
biotech industry is very dependent on
clinical trials on bids by larger
companies so once you know a pfizer or
you know any other big pharmaceutical
company comes in and decides they want
to buy this company that's typically
when these executives will cash out
right now they're not allowed to cash
out before it it's an M&A contingent it
depends I mean if it depends on the
structure of their options on the terms
of their options typically though if
they're taken over and then fired after
the deal the you know the bigger company
says okay you've done your job that's
when they can typically cash out on
these options what does this mean for
the executives themselves i mean the
success is there but this these are all
paper games
at the end of the day we had a really
great quote from a compensation analyst
in this story who said that these these
this wealth can be fleeting so you know
you have a good clinical trial one day
and then you have poor results the next
day and your paper gains can can go away
it's all dependent on your actually did
that sort of make the CEOs want to do
M&A more than they would if they weren't
compensated through an M&A buyout I mean
hey if I'm gonna make a billion dollars
if I get bought out I'm gonna want to
push for that yeah of course of course
and then we actually when we've looked
at the history of some of these
executives we've seen that they've moved
from small biotech firm to small biotech
firm kind of selling and selling and
selling to bigger companies and cashing
out on their comp